CAM TALBOT.
FIVE GAMES IN MASHUPS.
>> IT IS HARD MASHUPS, THE OTHER
KULIKOV WEARING A NEW NUMBER.
SPARK. HEAVY GUYS
ALONG THE WALL, THAT'S A GREAT
START WHISTLE.
AND WITH THAT WHISTLE THEY WERE
ABLE TO GET ON IT
KNOCKED DOWN BY CAM TAL AHEAD.
AND HE WORKS
OFTEN.
THEY ARE KIND OF PLAYING MAN ON
MAN. ANOTHER, PART OF THE ONE JD
OVERLY CONFIDENT AND THEY ARE
PLAYING FROM
KINGS, BUT THAT BEHIND.
THE IT TAKES IT OFF
THE SHEET, SCORED BY
THE GLASS AND THEY'VE GOT THEIR
MONEY'S ICE, THE PLACE
>> I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW THEY HAD
A GREEN HELMET ALREADY.
DOESN'T TAKE
THE BEST.
WHAT A THEN COMING TO
CENTER ICE WE HAVE
>> THE GOAL FOR BRODIN.
DEFLECTING WIDE.
AND HE CHIPS
AND AN ICING THEM.HE SHOT SAVED.
SEVEN-GAME SERIES NET. OWN. TO
CENTER.E EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES AROUND THE FRONT OF Y
CARRIER.
PLAYING IT INTO
MISFIR
TEAMS.
AND IN THEIR BEST
[CHEERS]D ERIKSSON-EK WITH THE
TAKEAWAY AT CENTER.